all right there are very concrete habits
that you can use that i have used once
you get your mind in the right place
once you believe that it can happen
this is what i did i worked out why
because it helped me gain control of my
mind one it was micro credibility with
myself every day i said i was going to
do something i did it two when you're
suffering and you're willing to fight
through it you tell yourself a story
that you're willing to pay the price to
become what you want to become and also
and this may be the most important
reason each and every one of you should
start working out and it has nothing to
do with living longer because we could
get hit by a meteorite who knows so i'm
not even worried about that but i am
worried about this
when you watch your body transform you
get the loudest signal from your
subconscious that you can change that
you can change anything you want that
you can change your bicep your tricep
your quad whatever it is you want
something that you literally could not
do the day before you can do today
and your mind sees that that's true
your mind sees that something you
couldn't pick up yesterday you can pick
up today and it begins to ask itself
well if that's possible then what else
is possible
now for me finding my center was also a
very important thing so i work out first
the next thing i do without fail is
meditate i do a just breathe meditation
where i'm simply trying to calm my mind
then i do what i call thinkitating
during meditating i get into an alpha
wave state brain pattern which enhances
creativity and unique connections i'm
not worried about whether i'll ever
think a unique thought i am simply
interested in the unique connections
that i will make that no one else before
me or after me will ever make because
their circumstances are different than
mine and that to me is what makes each
of us a beautiful snowflake
is we're all going to make connections
that other people might not make and so
during thinking i take advantage of a
problem i'm trying to solve i smash it
together with my alpha wave state and i
see what comes out of it i read i read
obsessively
because i believe in one simple math
equation ideas in equal ideas out and
then i keep a list of the most important
things i'm trying to accomplish if
you're trying to become something you
need to know what that something is
you are what you consistently do the
difference between where you are right
now and where you want to be is what are
you consistently doing every single day
your habits will determine your ultimate
success one of the reasons why i've had
so much success on youtube is because i
just keep making videos it's a habit
it's burned into my calendar
every week i am making videos i film i'm
here making this content for you guys
now i'm making more videos more videos
more videos more videos it's
consistently been a part of my routine
for over a decade
if you do something every single week or
more frequent for a decade you're gonna
get some serious results you'd have to
be
just absolutely terrible to not get any
results if you're doing something every
single week or more frequently for a
decade most people don't want to put in
the work and i get it and that can be
frustrating it can be slow we want the
instant results
and it's hard to shift the identity your
identity at the beginning
because your habits of not doing
something or your current habits that
you are doing are stronger than the new
habit that you're trying to build
so for me not to make a video would be
so foreign so weird i've made videos
through all sorts of crisis and and
tragedies and
injuries the only time when i didn't
make videos was when my dog died when my
family dog died it was on video day and
i just couldn't bring myself to making
the videos so the only week where i like
zero i can't do it
we have to do something else but i've
made videos through
vacations i've made videos through
breaking my neck i've made videos
through
everything every tragedy that's happened
every negative every every stress every
frustration i've found a way to make
videos it's so a part of me now not
because i'm superhuman or extra special
just because i put the reputation in
now a new habit that i'm trying to build
is swimming
the pool just opened back up in my place
and i've gone swimming
every day for the past two weeks
week and a half i'm going swimming and
it's so it's so fun it's so freeing i go
for my swim i started i could only do 20
lengths of the pool now i'm up to 40 and
i'm getting better at it and i feel i
just feel so good you swim you have a
shower and then like oh my body feels
amazing right now
but it's still a new habit
right i'm still trying to develop it if
i were to go
and fly to a speaking gig and then come
back i would have to force myself to get
back into oh right swimming swimming
that's what i'm supposed to do in the
morning i gotta go swimming right right
right i'd have to set up reminders i
have to put it in my calendar
but making videos is so ingrained
because it's lasted so long because i've
done it feels super weird if i if i left
youtube or sold my channel or whatever
like oh what do i do now i don't even
know what to do anymore because
making videos has become part of my
identity
you too can change your identity you too
can start to develop the habits that
will help take you to accomplishing your
goals i want to give three quick tips
that i think will help you step number
one
is to get really clear on what the habit
is that you want to develop don't pick
20 different habits that you would want
to do all at once this is where we we
struggle because we take on way too much
like okay that's it i'm done
i'm rolling up my sleeves it's time to
change my life i've had it i've had
enough i'm gonna change everything i'm
gonna work out and i'm gonna i'm gonna
eat well and i'm gonna make content i'm
gonna grow my business i'm gonna find a
girlfriend i'm gonna like whatever the
thing is you come with 20 different
habits that you're going to do
and guess what you do it tomorrow maybe
and then and then it becomes too
overwhelming too much too much change
all at once
your life
just takes over and you end up back down
in the hole where you started has that
happened have you tried to take on too
much at once what is the single most
important habit that you need to start
to build that if you look back in a year
you could say i'm so happy that i built
this one habit because it's helping you
accomplish your goals what is the most
important habit it could be waking up at
a certain time it could be taking care
of your your mind it could be taking
care of your body it could be putting in
a certain amount of work on your
business it could be right in your book
it could be making 100 videos like what
is the one habit
that you want to start to build that if
that one thing happened
your entire life starts to change
it's the cornerstone habit that you
start doing that because i guarantee you
listen if you start
waking up at a certain time or you start
working out you pick any of them you
start doing one of those things
that you're proud of yourself for doing
it
other things start to change in your
life around you because when you feel
really proud of yourself when you feel
good about yourself other things start
to improve too
because if you were say your goal is to
make 100 videos next year okay so every
three days you're making a video
and that's impossible you've never done
that and that sounds crazy and it's way
too big and then you start to do it
you start that you build the momentum
you start to actually make the content
it's like okay well what else what else
can i do
you know what i want to i want to i want
to start working on my health
it's just going to happen naturally you
want to find a relationship people will
gravitate towards you
because now the sudden you're a lot more
confident a lot more proud that's
magnetic energy that people want to be
around
so you pick the one habit that you want
to stay consistent on
and then you start doing that work not
being stressed out about having too many
habits all at once and the whole thing
fails
okay step number two you have to
schedule it
you have to put it in your calendar
schedule it it will not just happen
these videos are happening for me right
now
it's in my schedule
i book time for
i have swimming in my schedule that's
that's even more important in my
calendar
so today at five o'clock i'm gonna go
swimming it's in my calendar i booked it
because otherwise other stuff could come
in maybe i get on a roll i'm making
videos or maybe somebody messages me and
i have to deal with it something else
will always come up something else will
always come up right stuff always comes
up
and we let that be an excuse for you not
to take action
you block it off you put it in your
calendar show yourself when
right which day of the week are you
actually going to be doing this thing or
which time of day are you actually going
to be doing this thing
and start to teach yourself that this
gets done that when you put less things
in your calendar right put less things
in your calendar and make sure that they
get done because you can put stuff in
you how many times you put stuff on your
calendar or anything get done
right does that happen to you
don't worry about that
less things in your calendar but when
you put it in it gets done again this is
building the identity it's you starting
to trust yourself that when you say
something's gonna happen that it happens
and that just happens one off but it
happens consistently
so you if you've got holidays coming up
or vacation coming up and your goal is
still to do videos or swimming or right
write a page for your book or whatever
it is that is part of your goals
plan your calendar
show yourself what time okay you know
you're traveling tomorrow
okay you're gonna do it before you
travel you're gonna do it while you're
on the plane you're gonna do it when you
land in the city and what's realistic
are you going to be doing a 16-hour
flight with two stopovers and then be
exhausted when you land and that's when
you're going to do your workout
right like maybe work out in the morning
like just think about your day that's
coming ahead of you and schedule that
thing in
because again when you can stay
consistent on it that's when everything
starts to change
and then number three
is get a community
doing something
difficult
and doing something brand new
is really really really hard to do by
yourself it's not impossible it's not
that you can't do it but we are
we are community people like humans are
even even me who's introverted and shy
and i don't need a lot of friends
it's always more fun doing something
with somebody knowing that tonight at
five nina's going swimming with me
i'm more likely to show up because
nina's there too
it's gonna be a lot more fun because
nina's there too get somebody to be an
accountability partner for you join a
discord group or facebook group that are
talking about these things so that you
don't feel like you're the only person
going through this because when you have
a down day when you have a bad moment
when you're tired when you had a rough
sleep when you got a terrible news
it's easy to fall right back down to the
habits that you've been
consistently working on the negative
habits you've been building up over your
lifetime instead of defaulting back to
the positive ones that you want to start
to build
the difference between where you are
right now and where you want to be are
the habits you consistently do you are
what you consistently do
[Music]
you eat one chocolate bar it's fine as
long as you're consistently eating
really well but if you eat really well
only one day and you're eating chocolate
bars every day then guess what's going
to happen to your health
you are what you consistently do and you
can change it
you can change it where you are right
now does not have to be where you are in
one year if you put the habits in place
if you consistently schedule them in
and you get a community to help you so
you're not doing this alone
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
you can't make a racehorse out of a pig
but you can make a really fast pig
your life can be the answer to what does
a fast pig look like that is certainly
what my life is all the success that
i've had in my life is not because i was
gifted at any one thing when i left for
college my mother quietly assumed i was
going to fail my best friend assumed i
was going to marshmallow my way through
life when i asked my father-in-law for
his blessing to marry his daughter he
said no
and yet i went on to be successful to
earn my father-in-law's respect um
not because they misidentified me
because they didn't they were right
but because i developed drive i got the
only belief that mattered and i finally
realized that
humans are meant to grow and get better
at something and i just have to apply
myself and the same is true for you
decide what you want to get good at and
go after it with everything you've got
and that my friends
is how you overcome negativity as henry
rollins said
i don't have talent
so i just get up earlier
the thing that people think about
becoming great
about doing the extraordinary is that
it's just meant for some people and not
meant for others
and they spend their time making other
people extraordinary
as a way to let themselves off the hook
because if somebody is just gifted if
they were blessed by god if they were
touched by an angel and they just have
something that you don't and something
that you never will have
then it's fine for them to be great and
you to be ordinary but the reality is
it's not how it works
but somehow the cultural narrative has
become one where we celebrate
natural talent
that if somebody is graced by god that
if they have something divine about them
that they're somehow better that it's
more beautiful than the scrappy person
who's had to work for everything they've
ever had the guy who simply acknowledges
like henry rollins that he doesn't have
more talent than the next person he's
simply willing to outwork them he's
willing to set the alarm to get up to do
whatever it takes to find his path to
create that skill to out work talent to
show that by putting in that energy and
that effort there's a magnification
effect that is far greater than anything
that can be given to you bestowed upon
you you have to grab it you have to take
it you have to have a level of intensity
in your life
to be able to leverage it and create
something amazing
and as warren buffett said intensity is
the price of excellence
if you want to be great
you've got to cultivate that intensity
you've got to understand it's not about
what you were born with it's not about
what you were given where you started or
even where you're going it is entirely
about what you plant at the center of
your soul how hard you're willing to go
after something how much focus you're
willing to put in your life and how
often you come back to that level of
intensity for who you want to be
[Music]
[Applause]
because if you want to be excellent
you will have to pay a price
and that price is eternal vigilance
vigilance over how you spend your time
vigilance over the demands you make of
yourself vigilance over what you allow
yourself to think and believe
and when you get to the point that you
only allow yourself to think and believe
things and move you towards your goals
that every day the actions you take are
things that are designed to get you
there and that you have the intensity to
follow that through to shape yourself to
create a new version of you capable of
doing something extraordinary
then your life is going to be what you
want
but not until then
it's never going to be anything if you
just make other people extraordinary and
say i could never do that
but the reality is you could
and you're just not
so the thing that you have to face right
now is that it is within your grasp
you just have to go after it and let me
tell you passion is not something you
were born with drives me nuts everybody
thinks they're going to turn inside like
an archaeologist and find that thing
their deepest passion the thing they
always love hiding inside
is as soon as you say it i hope it
sounds ridiculous that you would love
something that much and yet somehow be
blind to it
it doesn't work like that
it's like real love you've got to go on
a date first
you see somebody you're interested in
you talk to them it sparks something you
spend time you engage
and through that process of engaging
with it
maybe if you're lucky it turns into a
fascination
but if you really want a passion
you've got to go through the process of
gaining mastery
and mastery is the part of the
relationship in business or in romance
where everybody falls apart
because it's where the work starts
it's where you have to do things long
after it stopped being fun now the
process of taking myself from scrounging
my couch cushions to find enough change
to put gas in my car
to building a billion dollar business
was all about building a set of beliefs
now i believe
that the matrix has us all
i don't actually think we live in a
simulation but i think the movie the
matrix is the perfect metaphor for the
human experience we have all pulled a
web of lies over our own eyes and the
web of lies is what you tell yourself
about what's possible for you and for
the world
and once you
get that web of lies over your eyes you
simply see it as reality and you don't
understand that each one of those
fundamental beliefs is alterable that
you could choose to believe something
else in fact you don't even realize that
they are beliefs
einstein has a quote it's one of the
most important quotes in my life
the most important question
any man must decide for himself is
whether or not he lives in a friendly or
hostile universe
now what i love about that quote so
what's hiding in it is that it's a
decision
you get to choose
whether you're living in a friendly or a
hostile universe
there's no objective reality
it just is what it is you're gonna get
what you see you're gonna get what you
focus on
and you see what you focus on so many
people are obsessed with becoming
perfect that they never take action and
they never learn to enjoy this moment
that may be one of the greatest
tragedies any of us can face
that right now whatever we are however
we are however good we are whatever
we've accomplished
that we failed to enjoy this moment
because we have a judgment about who we
are deep down because we haven't acted
in a way that's perfect and i get it we
have this drive it's innate in us we
want to be great
it's one of the five primary human
drivers to pursue mastery to want to
master something and truly be
extraordinary
i understand the drive
but don't let it corrode you don't ever
do something that eats you alive from
the inside
you've got to have a vision of yourself
that allows you to morph and change and
learn from your mistakes but if you
value perfection over learning then
you're never going to become the person
that you'd be capable of becoming
and as anna quindlin said the thing that
is really hard and really amazing
is giving up on being perfect
and beginning the work of becoming
yourself
let me tell you something that is true
beyond measure
the struggle is guaranteed
the success is not
the struggle is a guarantee
so you better love what you do on a
day-to-day basis
read eckhart tolle's the power of now
the only moment that's real is right now
now follows you so every time you're
doing something if you're standing and
staring and waiting for someone to
finish going to the restroom or whatever
you're standing in line at disneyland
that is your life that is the sum total
of what you are about in that moment and
life is simply a string of those moments
and so you've got to start asking
yourself am i using those moments wisely
everything around you
is
incredible if you're willing to look at
it that way everything around you can be
taken for granted if that's your
perspective
but it really is about the frame that
you choose to put around things i mean
simply being alive is already insane the
odds are so stacked against you not only
just being a human but being a human at
this moment in time this moment in time
where breakthroughs and technology are
happening at
at an unprecedented rate where
breakthroughs in medical science are
happening at an unprecedented rate where
our ability to connect with people to
empathize with people all the way around
the globe all of the changes that have
happened in technology and telecom and
connectivity health everything
we're living in
the most miraculous time ever
but you have to look at it that way
and as joseph campbell said life is a
wonderful wonderful opera
except that it hurts
so the question is do you see it as the
beautiful opera or do you just pay
attention to the pain
and at the end of the day you're going
to get what you focus on they're both
true
this is both the most amazing time
that's ever happened ever in recorded
history
and yet real things that are terrifying
are also happening
but where you put your energy where you
put your attention where you put your
focus is going to determine what you see
and that is the most fascinating and the
most important thing you have to
understand about the way that your mind
works you get what you focus on if you
focus on the things that are bad they
will become real they will become
exaggerated they will begin to
monopolize your thoughts you'll see them
everywhere it's called the reticular
activating system your mind is literally
designed
to pay attention
to the things that you notice
once you notice a certain car you see it
everywhere once you notice a certain dog
you see it everywhere once you hear a
certain name for the first time suddenly
realize that that name has been all
around you this entire time but now that
you're focusing on it now that you're
looking for it it is everywhere
so whatever you look for
it's going to be everywhere
if you look for the negative it'll be
there but if you look for the positive
it will overwhelm you and if you guys
haven't read the book
anti-fragile by naseem teleb do
in that book he lays out the difference
between something that is resilient
and something that is truly anti-fragile
i'm gonna say somebody that's
unstoppable is truly anti-fragile and
what anti-fragile is
the more you attack it the stronger it
gets so something that is resilient or
tough it is still defined by its
breaking point the more you go after it
eventually it will break
something that's anti-fragile grows with
that
and i believe each and every one of us
can build a mindset that is truly
anti-fragile there is only one thing
that i have found that is actually
anti-fragile and it looks like this
i was there with my partners they
routinely made me feel stupid all the
time they were older than me they were
more than ten years ahead of me on their
entrepreneurial journey
and so i was just wrong all the time
now up to that point in my life i
actually called myself the king of
remedial jobs up until then i'd only
gone for jobs where i knew i'd be
smarter than the person interviewing me
i knew that at some point during the
interview they were going to ask that
magical question which made me feel so
good about myself
which was why are you here
why are you interviewing for this job
and i lived for that because it made me
feel smart
so here i am now not in that world
anymore i'm with guys who are way ahead
of me they're way smarter than me
and i feel dumb all the time and one day
i find myself arguing for this
path in our business because it was my
idea and i knew it was wrong that was a
hilarious thing i knew it was wrong and
yet i was arguing for it like really
passionately and then all of a sudden it
actually worked
and they agreed to do it and i thought
oh
now what
i've been telling my wife that i'm gonna
make her rich and here i am arguing for
something that just makes me feel good
about myself
and i had this moment of crisis
and i asked myself
no judgment
what do you really want because if what
you really want is to feel good about
yourself to feel smart
to be right
to be worthy
if those are the things that you want
then get out of this company because
you're wrong often you're making
mistakes all the time and your partners
are so far ahead of you that they make
you feel stupid
so this is like that doesn't make any
sense so if you
want to just go feel good go back to
being the king of remedial jobs be in
places where you're always feeling smart
where you're usually right
and live that life
but if on the other hand
what you really want is to actually
reach your goals
then you're going to have to stop
worrying about feeling good about
yourself
and both of those felt flawed
everybody needs to feel good about
themselves
that that's just the reality of being a
human you've got to find a way to feel
good about yourself
but i really believe
everything you do in life should be in
service of your goals
and the moment that you're acting out of
alignment with your goals you either
have a problem with your goal or with
your behavior one of them is going to
have to change
and so i realized in that moment
that i needed to change what i was
building my self-esteem around because i
was building it around being right and i
was wrong so much i was building it
around being smart and i just wasn't
that smart i was building it around
being good and worthy
and the fact is those were just
judgments on myself
and so i decided right then and there
it's the one thing in my life that
borders on truly being an epiphany
and i realized i need to change what i
build my self-esteem around and it needs
to be something
that i didn't have the word anti-fragile
at the time but something that the more
somebody goes after it the better off
i'm going to be the more it's going to
push me towards my goals and that thing
is and if somebody has a better answer i
will take it but the only
way to build your ego that is truly
anti-fragile that i have found is to be
the learner
to be willing to admit when you're wrong
to look at your goal and work backwards
and say is what i'm doing actually
moving me towards my goal or not not
does it make me feel good about myself
not am i right not am i smart is it
moving me towards my goal and if it is
then you do it and if it doesn't then
you don't
and my life became that cut and dry and
you can literally draw a line in the
sand a demarcation point of my life
before that and my life after that as
kurt vonnegut one of the greatest
authors in modern times said
when i write
i feel like an armless legless man with
a crayon in his mouth
but he still did it
and that's the kind of thing that you're
going to hear from the greats you're not
going to hear that it was easy you're
not going to hear that they felt suave
and cool even the greatest of all time
have that awkwardness not clumsiness
they're never quite as good as they want
to be but what i want you to understand
is even though kurt vonnegut said those
words
he wrote
tons
of books
that changed people's lives that changed
the landscape of literature because
despite the fact that he felt awkward
and clumsy he kept doing it and doing it
and forcing himself to move forward to
take one step after another even when
the process
was not exactly rewarding
he believed in something he knew that
what he was trying to do would
ultimately
get better he knew that if he wanted to
accomplish something great that he had
to push through the awkwardness and that
is the very trick to getting great
you just have to do it you have to go
you have to take that first step you
have to push you have to drive you have
to strive every time to get a little bit
better you have to strive not to fall
prey to your own doubts and insecurities
and as joe namath said
if you aren't going all the way why go
at all
whatever your skill set is
now whatever your vision of yourself is
now
you can change it
you can become anything you want to be
but life is going to ask you one simple
question
what price are you willing to pay to get
there
and that's it that's the hard truth if
you're willing to pay the price and you
can become whatever you want you can
become truly capable of the
extraordinary
but you've got to go through the process
of building that skill set you've got to
be willing to stare nakedly at your
inadequacies
to understand that you aren't yet the
person that you want to be or need to be
to execute against your goals but that
you can become that person and then
start walking down that path and day by
day brick by brick build the skill set
that you want as haroon yaya noted
i always wonder why birds stay in the
same place when they can fly anywhere on
earth
and then i ask myself the same question
as mark twain put it
the secret of getting ahead is getting
started
and that's where people get stuck you're
literally like the bird you could fly
anywhere you want you can go
anywhere you want to go and look i know
you've got a litany of excuses and all
of them are valid you've got a job you
can't just leave or you don't have a job
and you don't have the money your family
is in one place it's the only thing that
you've ever known you only speak one
language you've never traveled before
you don't have a passport you can't
afford the gas money there are a
thousand
real
reasons
not to go
but the truth is that none of them
matter the truth is if you want to build
something in your life then you have to
remember what mark twain said you have
to get started because at the end of the
day that is literally the only thing
that's holding you back
you're not moving and once you get the
simplicity of that once you understand
that you could act right now
you could say all the excuses you could
stop making them you could stop giving
in to them no matter how
valid they are no matter how real they
may seem you can
finally decide that you're going to get
up a move that you're going to create
that momentum that you're going to take
a step that you're going to make the
demand that you create momentum that you
get something done that you
find an answer or as hannibal said that
you're going to find a way or make one
if you have to carve through
rock do it because humans before you
have done it
and that's the simple truth that is the
simple
truth and everything else everything
else is the weak voice in your mind
holding you back and making you a less
version of yourself so i ask you
why doesn't the bird fly wherever it
wants to
because that's all it's known
because that's what's safe
because that's what's comfortable
or because it's a dumb
animal
what do you want to be
if this isn't the life you want to live
do something about it humans lead with
belief
that may be the single most important
thing to understand humans lead with
belief meaning you don't do something
and then believe you can do it you won't
even take the first step if you don't
believe that your actions will be
rewarded with results that's why so many
people are paralyzed because
they think that they're not worthy they
think they're or they know they're
uneducated
they know that they're not the person
that they need to be in order to
accomplish and the reality is you're
probably not
the fact is your skill set has already
taken you as far as it's going to take
you so if you
are unsatisfied with where you are today
i have some horrifying news for you i'll
chase it with some good news but first
let's start with the bad
the bad news is
your life
is an exact reflection
of the choices you've made
that's it
it's not circumstance it comes down to
skill set and choices you've chosen to
build a certain skill set you've chosen
to do certain things take certain risks
play certain things safely whatever the
case may be those were all choices now
your life is a reflection of that what i
want you to understand though the belief
the only belief that you need to have
that thing
that is going to allow you to take that
first step
is not to believe
that you're capable
of what you're trying to build
because we all know you're not i knew
that i wasn't when we started quest i
knew i wasn't the person that i needed
to be i understood that
it just didn't paralyze me
because i believed one thing
and if you take nothing else from what i
say today burn the following statement
into your soul
humans
are
the ultimate adaptation machine
that's it
charles darwin is often misquoted as
saying that it's the strongest of the
species that survive
he'd never said that
what he actually said
was it's not the strongest of the
species that survived nor the most
intelligent but rather the most adaptive
to change
we're the apex predator for a reason
because unlike any other animal we have
the ability to go in any direction any
direction we want we're the only species
that you can find anywhere at one point
james cameron was actually at the bottom
of the marianas trench
we can thrive anywhere
from inuits
living in the tundra
to peoples that have survived in the
desert
because humans adapt that is the
fundamental nature of what we are so
then these two successful entrepreneurs
walk into my class and up to that point
i'd promised myself two things so i grew
up chubby in a morbidly obese family
and
with no money and i said one day i'm
gonna be rich and one day i'm gonna have
six-pack abs
and that was my promise and these guys
walked in and they were rich and they
had six-pack abs
and they said look we're starting a
technology company why don't you come be
a copywriter
and i was like absolutely and it's one
of those where people like what are you
doing like you're leaving the secure job
for me i was like they're like unicorns
to me yeah they are literally the thing
i'm looking for yeah they are rich and
they have six-pack abs they're going to
let me into their company yeah and so
their whole pitch was look man this is a
startup you can have any job in this
company you want you just have to become
the right person for the job so it was a
tech company it was in this beautiful
office overlooking the pacific ocean
every single person in that company had
a floor-to-ceiling window overlooking
the pacific ocean except me and they put
me in the server room which had no
windows and a bunch of computers all
worrying and making noise and i remember
one of the guys was like who's the kid
in the server room and so that's how i
became known i was the kid in the server
room i know anything about business i
would bring my wife jesus to visit me in
the office and i'm like look how
beautiful the office is and this is
where i'm at you know like literally
like those makeshift desks that are like
really like a table that you would use
on a picnic but you've got a computer
stacked on it that's where i worked all
day do you believe big time that
identity's shaped by these associations
in everybody's life 100 talk about that
for a second so it's so aggressive and
it's now getting repeated so i fear
trite words but words become trite
because they're so true that people
repeat them until they lose their
meaning
so you're the average of the five people
you spend the most time with that's just
true
and but now it's become so common to say
and it's like every instagram post that
i fear it's going to lose its meaning
who are you spending time with because
if you're spending time with people like
you you're spending time with people
like me i'm i'm raising you up i'm just
not going to spend time with you
so it's like now if you get in a mix of
people like that who are like man we'd
love for you to raise up to this level
but if you don't it's fine but we're
just not going to spend time with you
all of a sudden that desire to belong to
something powerful that you can see is
going to lead you to your dreams and i
remember saying to my wife over and over
and over they are the surest path to my
success i don't know anything else i
just know if i can hang on to these guys
they're going to make me better
literally the first time i wrote this
whole article it was my first blog
article and it was all about how if i
were hit by a drunk driver i would take
ownership of that i would say that is my
fault and people were
pissed
and i was so shocked i literally thought
i want to pull people from the matrix
what's the one gift that i could give
people that will change their life
forever
and i wrote this whole thing and i was
like talking about like oh man you're in
this spot and it ends up being a kill
box and there's cars on either side of
you and a car in front of you and your
horn dies and you can't even start your
car and move you look in the rearview
mirror and this drunk driver is plowing
down they smash into you
and it's all your fault
and thank god
because now you remember that you're in
control
but people thought i was victim-shaming
people were outraged
that i would say that that was anyone's
fault but the drunk driver
but i don't want to do that
because i choose
not
to ever be a victim
i cannot choose whether i'm victimized
but i have the ability to say i will
never
be a victim
because there's always something you can
do differently
there is always something you can do
differently
and once you understand that you can
always make a different choice and get a
different reaction and that's the power
in your life that's the power that you
have is no matter what's going on you
can choose to think differently believe
differently see differently
all of those things are a choice
read man's search for meaning by viktor
frankl
lost his whole family to the holocaust
was in i think five different
concentration camps
and he said the thing that people die of
in a concentration camp
is the loss of a why
and nietzsche said if you have a why you
can survive almost anyhow
because you can always change how you
think about something
and when you change how you think about
it's what we've been talking about all
day when you change how you think about
it you actually change the event
here's the problem i find most people
have they judge themselves to the lens
of a moment
they fail at something
they miss
the honor club
they don't close that deal they thought
they were going to they embarrass
themselves they flub something
and they think that defines who they are
but i'm telling you right now you're not
defined by who you are you're defined by
who you want to become
and the price you're willing to pay to
get there here's the hard truth about
getting great
it takes time and dedication
it takes a willingness to accept that
you're not yet good enough it takes the
ability to stare at the places that you
know that you're weak to really look at
those things and not let it affect your
sense of self-esteem and not let it
affect your sense of self-worth so that
you can still get the momentum going but
you have to understand that in the
beginning
we're all terrible
and as henry cartier-bresson said your
first 10 000 photographs are your worst
and so the thing that really makes great
art are the people that continue to push
and the people that continue to work and
face how inadequate they are and really
understand that at the end of the day
greatness is a craft greatness is a
process
greatness
is a habit
greatness is the little things that you
do every day over time going out every
day unafraid of whether or not this is
one of the ten thousand terrible things
that you're going to do it's being
unafraid to make those mistakes is being
unafraid
that you're not yet great
and as marianne radmaker said
courage doesn't always roar
sometimes
courage is the quiet voice at the end of
the day saying
i will try again tomorrow
and that's it
if you want to be great that's what you
have to do you've got to get up again
tomorrow you've got to be willing to
face another day you've got to be
willing to accept that you've got to get
through the bad ideas before you can get
to the good you've got to understand
that you have to start as an apprentice
you have to start as a person going and
getting t and you have to accept that
that's the job that you should be
playing that you should be working for
somebody else you should be looking up
to somebody else's seeing what they can
teach you because what you know
is that you're there to learn what you
know is that you're there to get through
the 10
000 bad photographs that you need to get
through to ultimately achieve greatness
and if you make the catastrophic error
that so
many
make
to try to tell the world that you're
extraordinary today
to try to get the world to follow you
and look up to you and think that you're
something
today
because the people that really win are
the ones that invest
today the ones that listen today the
ones that spend every ounce of their
energy amassing mastery getting better
every day working their asses off to
improve their skill set to relentlessly
look at the things that they're not
doing well to understand that they have
to break themselves down and get rid of
all of their ego before they can really
find greatness
those are the people that we remember
so if you want to be remembered
if you want to achieve real greatness
you just need to have the courage to
show up every day
and take another swing
take another photo
try another task
do something that scares you
and do those little things over and over
and over
until you win so the one thing i will
say is i was grandly ambitious i always
said i'm going to be rich i'm going to
do this i'm going to do that always
always since the time i was a little kid
but i didn't have the drive to see it
through so i really really was an empty
dreamer when i was a kid and it was
learning to
hate that in myself if i'm completely
honest
and to not allow myself to be an empty
dreamer to force myself to get the
skills to actually execute against it to
not be in any way shape or form pacified
by saying i'm gonna do something which
is actually super dangerous most people
just thinking about the fantasy of what
they're gonna do gives them some partial
sense of oh i've done it
whereas i stopped letting that be okay
for me which largely came down to
embarrassment i felt around my wife
working when i had no job
and that was the time she was my fiance
at the time but that was when i really
started to go okay you've made a lot of
promises to this woman and you're not on
a path to keep any of them tom am i
going to make it
do i have what it takes
when you
look into my future can you see me
making it
and i'm going to cut to the chase for
all of you and you're going to mistake
what i'm about to say for good news
and then i'm going to tell you why it's
actually
the worst thing i could tell you
you all meet minimum requirements
you all meet minimum requirements
so whatever it is you want to do i'm not
going to say that it's going to be
easy for you because you're ultra smart
or something you probably aren't
but everyone that i've encountered here
literally without exception every single
person that has come up to me and said
something you meet minimum requirements
even you awkward to have a hard time
like making eye contact even you guys
i'm telling you right now you've got
some you're gonna have to deal with
but you meet minimum requirements now
minimum requirements for what
[Music]
for whatever you want
now that sounds great
right
tom said i can make it
this is amazing
but all i've actually said
is now
if you don't make it
it's on you
and that's it
there's nobody else to blame
everything
is your fault
everything once you understand the whole
reason to acquire a skill
is that it gives you power
now i'm going to define power
power to me
is the ability to close your eyes
and imagine a world the world the way
you wish it was
and then open your eyes
and make that world come true
that's power
and the thing that stands between you
where you are today and your goals where
you want to get
is a gap in skill set it is a gap in
abilities
and once you're willing to look nakedly
at your inadequacies to literally build
your self-esteem your entire sense of
self-worth and value is built around one
thing whenever you face an obstacle
whenever you face a difficulty whenever
you fail you have one thing that you say
to yourself
on a long enough timeline i can learn
this
when you switch your life around to that
whatever your goal is here whatever part
of the honors club or the leading edge
you're at or if you want to go beyond
that
whatever that is
wherever you want to go
plant that flag
identify the skills that you would need
to get there and then set about every
day getting those skills people get the
do part
they understand their actions should be
actions that take them towards what they
want to accomplish but people often miss
the most important part which is only to
believe
things that move you towards your goals
and i see people every day
that tell themselves the story about
themselves that they are worthless
that they're meaningless
that they're pointless
that their friends and family would be
better off if they just died
so we have to find a way to construct a
narrative about ourselves
that empowers us that lifts us up
even though
even though we make mistakes even though
we fall down even though
we're never going to get things right
all the time and even though terrible
things happen to us
or maybe we do terrible things
but in that
the erosion of the self
that's the danger the erosion of the
self that is the danger
and when i talk to people about the 80
20 principle 80 of the time you should
be focused on the things that you love
the beautiful things that you want to
bring to this world the beautiful things
that are already in the world
and 20 of the time you should be kicking
yourself in your ass and saying you can
do better
it's such a powerful idea
but the problem is when people get to
the twenty percent they forget that it's
only supposed to be twenty percent of
the time and that it's meant to be these
acute moments where you're pushing
yourself to be more to do more it isn't
so you can tear yourself down
that's why
you have to do and believe that which
moves you towards your goals and if
thinking that you're a worthless piece
of moves you to your goals somehow then
fine do it but i can't literally fathom
a universe in which that would be a
logical way to move forward
so i'm gonna give you the magic words
that you need right now to never fall
prey to that
believing i'm worthless
does not serve me
and i don't do things that don't serve
me
repeat that in your head every time you
begin to disparage yourself here's the
harsh reality
you're just not good enough yet
as brian tracy said your true success in
life begins only when you make the
commitment to become excellent at what
you do
this is the gap that i see in most
people's lives
they've not yet made the commitment to
become extraordinary and the reason that
they haven't made that commitment yet is
they don't believe that they can they're
afraid of what it might take to get
there
they just don't want it enough that's
the reality most people don't want it
enough to face all of that they don't
want to face their inadequacies they
don't want to accept that they're gonna
have to go through that process that
gut-wrenching back-breaking process of
becoming great and every day lulls them
into this sense that there's always time
to do it tomorrow but the reality is
there is only now there is only today
and if you really want to do something
with your life that leaves your own jaw
on the floor that leaves you
in awe of what you've done
you're going to have to admit you're not
yet good enough
you've got to put in that work that
you've got to develop a set of skills
that simply can't be denied but if you
do that on the other side of getting
that good at falling in love with
something and working so hard that you
can feel yourself changing as a human
being on the other side of that is
something unimaginably beautiful
and as les brown said if you set goals
and go after them with all the
determination you can muster your gifts
will take you places
that will amaze you
that's what i want in my life and i hope
that's what you want in yours is to be
amazed to be amazed at how extraordinary
this life really is this opportunity to
make of yourself anything you want to be
really think about that for a second you
can become anything you want to become
you can become an astronaut a
world-class athlete a musician the best
parent that this world has ever seen
anything you want is yours for the
taking
but it takes
effort it takes a willingness to stare
nakedly at your inadequacies it takes a
willingness to really gut check yourself
about where you are today and it doesn't
mean that you can't go and be something
better tomorrow and falling in love with
that process that knowing that being a
human and really getting the most out of
your potential is that to know that
tomorrow i can be better than i am today
and that doesn't make you a bad person
today
it's okay to know that you can be better
tomorrow and still love yourself
today
but it's also okay to love yourself
today and demand
that you get better tomorrow
and once you can do that
there is literally nowhere you can't go
so i would get kicked in the face and i
would do something really dumb i'd be
called an idiot told how stupid i was
and then i'd just be like all right i
need to re-center and that just became
my obsession i need to be able to
emotionally get back to complete neutral
so fast that you don't even see a
register on my face how'd you do it how
do you do that
literally practice so i could get i
could be in a situation where i'm being
berated or i legitimately mess up and it
costs money and it's like whoa that's on
me and it is nobody's bad but my own and
i realized that what most people do
their strategy is to deflect it it's
your fault it's not my fault yes so i
started thinking of this as a metaphor
people are throwing gold at me they're
throwing it really hard and i can put a
shield up and deflect it but then i lose
that piece of gold if i drop my shield
and just take the pain let it hit me in
the head then i bend down and go this
thing which was me being stupid there's
a lesson here and now i have this piece
of gold but the whole thing is i have to
be defenseless so i have to own it i
have to take it i can't fight if someone
is like this to this day if our team is
like hey there's something we need to
point out to you i'll do this
i square up to it i want them to know
like hey i want to hear it i want to
know like i want to be literally
physically open i'm not going to close
down i'm going to do everything i can to
square off to open myself so that they
know i'm receptive to the criticism
right because that's the nugget of gold
what i know is it's going to hurt it's
going to sting but if i can emotionally
re-center so fast you don't even see
that i went through something now i can
just process how do i take this
information you've given me and get
better
i went through the pain of living the
cliche money camp by happiness early so
that was the very thing that gave birth
to my true financial success so walk me
through that though so most people will
never experience what it's like to come
into crazy wealth yeah it is it is a
really funny moment and funny is the
right word
it's it's fun
but it's also funny in that
when i
was growing up part of the reason i
wanted to get rich was i looked at those
people with admiration and i did not
look at myself with admiration so i
thought oh well if i can get wealthy
then i will look at myself with
admiration this would be amazing and
then when i got the money by then i had
changed myself fundamentally as a person
and i had earned so much self-respect
and so much self-worth that by the time
i got the money i didn't i wasn't
looking for anything from the money
other than it is the great facilitator
it will let you do extraordinary things
but it won't make you an extraordinary
person it won't make you feel any
differently about yourself and because
the money came literally like that
because we had paper wealth so i was a
worth hundreds of millions of dollars on
paper but i just cannot stress enough
that's meaningless in your real life i
was driving you know at one point a beat
up ford focus my wife and i had to share
it had a leaky exhaust and yet i'm worth
at that point i was worth tens of
millions of dollars but there were
employees that were living far better
lives than i was from a financial
standpoint so that's paper money now
bank account money came in an instant
and so it was about i don't know six
years into our journey and we um decided
to take a small investment to diversify
so it was a pure founder liquidity
moment and
because the valuation of the company was
over a billion dollars you can imagine
even at a small percentage just the raw
number of dollars is insanity
so
all of a sudden i was fantastically
wealthy but i was like
it is so in fact this this was how that
day went so
everyone i said earlier you beliefs
values identity habits routines right
these are the things that make people up
and i just have a value system that says
it's not about the money it's about
building something you believe in it's
about serving other people it's about
work ethic it's about showing up and
working and i value myself for that so
on the day that the money hit it hit it
like i don't know 8 a.m in the morning
or something
and my wife we're both in the gym
and she's like what are we gonna do
today and i was like what do you mean
i'm going to work
and she like couldn't wrap her head
around that huh she's like whoa whoa
we're gonna go to the lamborghini dealer
yeah she's like come on we've gotta like
go do something we've gotta celebrate
and i'm like there's no universe in
which i don't show up for work today
none under no circumstances so if you
were to ask my employees when did the
money hit they'll be like i have no idea
they knew that it did hit but they
didn't know what day because i acted
completely the same and the thing that i
want people to understand is i feel the
same so all of the like things that i
believe about myself to be good i still
believe to be good i earned them i
earned them by doing the hard thing time
and time and time and time again i know
how much i'm willing to serve people and
my family and myself and all i just know
i've done it for years and years and
years so when it came to do i buy an
island and retire or do i double down it
came down to what will make me
love my life the most and the reality is
the thing that would make me love my
life the most because it would still be
fun to just go and be with my wife but
the thing that'll make me love my life
the most is to do the things that are
fulfilling and i think fulfillment has a
very specific universal formula and that
formula is
work your ass off to get very good at
something that you care deeply about
that allows you to serve not only
yourself but other people that's it and
for me it was i grew up in a morbidly
obese family my uncle essentially ate
himself to death when i was 12 years old
it was scary and sad my mom is morbidly
obese has been my entire life my
sister's morbidly obese has been almost
her entire life
my dad at one point was morbidly obese
and then lost weight but it was like
that's just where my family lived
and so i was like they're going to die
far sooner than they need to and there's
this great mother teresa quote
nobody will act for the many but people
will act for the one and so i just
needed to wake up every day and think
about my mom and my sister and that was
it and i thought i can show up every day
and fight for them it's not about the
money anymore here's
this may be the biggest problem we face
as a society
people don't remember that skills have
utility they let you do something
you don't learn to build a house to
impress your parents you learn to build
a house so people can live in the house
you build and once people understand
that like holy
you're building this house so somebody
can live in it build a home in it have a
family be sheltered from storms like
it's a real thing man and so all of that
effort and energy went into i have the
chills right now is so you can create
that moment for yourself for other
people it is it is something so much
more than going to architecture school
which maybe you went to because your
parents wanted that and they they were
architects and so you do that thing for
that and you forget that the whole
reason you became an architect was to
build houses
and so once people realize oh
i'm putting all of this time and energy
to build these things because they let
me do something what do i want to do
what do i want to give what do i want to
create when you look at skills from that
perspective it is like it is being a
superhero it is being a superhero you're
going to collect these abilities these
abilities actually let you do something
the fact that superman can fly allows
him to save people allows him to do
things other people can't do we all have
this opportunity to become capable of
the extraordinary to be able to do
things other people can't do and that
feels so good if you want more
inspiration morning videos they're not
on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it it's right
there next to me go click it there
continue to believe and i'll see you
there